grandma millie is shrinking her height
decreases by a quarter centimeter each
year
she wants to predict the total change in
her height over the next
over the next three years
which of the following equations matches
the situation above
so our height is decreasing so we could
view that as the change in our height
each year is a negative fourth of a
centimeter and that's going to happen
for three years so we'd multiply
negative 1 4 times 3 which is exactly
what's happening in this first choice
right over here her height is decreasing
by a quarter centimeter each year that's
this part right over here and she's
doing this she's doing this for three
years so after three years her height
change in height would be negative
three-fourths of a centimeter you just
multiply this out which is a means
that's which means that she lost
three-fourths of a centimeter now the
second choice would evaluate if you
multiply positive one-fourth times
negative 3 you still get negative 3 4
but this doesn't seem to follow as
naturally from the statement up here
we're decreasing by a fourth so i like
putting the negative in front of the
fourth and then we're going in forward
in time by three years it feels weird to
put a negative on the three
so we're not going backwards in time
here so even though this this expression
evaluates to the same thing as this
first one the first one seems to better
match what this this statement is
describing and i wouldn't pick none of
the above just because i've i found one
that i like that i think describes an
equation that matches the situation
above let's do another one of these
a zombie lost three limbs each day for
four days who's going to lose 12 limbs
three times four
and so
and it's not a human zombie it's my
alien zombie that has at least 12 limbs
to lose the following equation describes
the situation so the zombie lost
three limbs each day so lost three limbs
so negative three could represent hey if
i i'm losing three limbs the negative is
it's going my number of limbs is going
down by three so this is negative three
and it's doing that it's doing that for
four days
for four days and we have negative 12
which is the total number of limbs that
our zombie loses
so what does negative 12 tell us why i
just said it
the zombie lost a total of 12 limbs over
this time period yep that looks right
now let's see what are these other ones
the zombie has negative 12 limbs
well no they to have negative 12 i don't
even know what a negative limb would
would be we don't know how many limbs
the zombie started with the zombie i
don't know if it might be some type of
centipede zombie or something it might
have had a hundred limbs and if it lost
12 of them it would now have 80 it would
now have 88 limbs and the zombie might
have had 12 limbs and now it has a zero
limbs
in fact i don't i don't even know how
you get to negative limbs so i don't i
don't i don't think this makes sense i'm
not going to pick none of the above
because i agree with this first choice
let's do one more of these
a certain whoops
all right
a certain reality tv show
lost so we're losing so a negative might
be a nice way to represent the loss lost
a total of nine thousand viewers
over the past three months so over three
months it lost the same number of
viewers each month
the following equation describes the
situation
so it lost a total of 9 000 viewers and
it did it over three months
so what they're figuring out here is how
much what was the change in viewership
what was the change in viewership per
month so it tells us the negative 3000
tells us that they lost on average on
average and actually tells us they lost
the same number so this is actually the
same number every month so it actually
they actually lost 3 000 viewers every
month so let's see which of these
choices match up to that
there are three thousand fewer people
watching the show compared to three
months ago
no they lost three thousand every month
that's what this is telling us every
month for three months there's the same
number each month they lost three
thousand every month for three months
for a total of nine thousand so this
isn't right
the total change in the number of people
watching the show is negative three
thousand
over a month that would be true but the
total change was nine thousand so
or negative nine thousand i guess i
could say they lost nine thousand and so
i would say none of the above what the
negative three thousand tells us if
there was a choice that said
each month they lost three thousand
viewers that's the choice that i would
pick
so i would say
none of the above